merci la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Pierre Vial pour le groupe UMP
oui le ministre très haut débit
constitue d'infrastructures au cœur de
l'avenir des territoires et la montagne
constitue une spécificité dans les
handicaps ne serait-elle une nouvelle
fois sous-estimée après les zones
d'ombres blanches et grises l'eau débit
n'a pas encore trouvé sa couleur nous
avons bien noté les engagements du
gouvernement à travers le plan France
très haut débit soulignant que ce
service devrait s'appuyer sur toutes les
technologies permettant d'apporter le
plus rapidement possible le meilleur
débit à tous nos concitoyens à travers
les différentes technologies mais nul ne
peut contester que le déploiement d'un
tel réseau ne peut être envisagé sur
l'engagement et l'investissement lourd
des collectivités sans lesquelles un
déploiement n'est pas envisageable en
dehors des zones amies et nécessite que
puisse leur être donné un certain nombre
d'assurances tant sur les moyens
financiers techniques et réglementaires
le premier engagement est bien
évidemment dans financier si le
gouvernement doit d'y assumer sa part
avec une contribution de 3,3 milliards
d'euros de subventions encore
convient-il que les territoires puissent
avoir l'assurance que ce handicap de la
montagne sera pris en compte dans les
critères d'accompagnement de l'État la
deuxième question concerne ce
déploiement des techn l'origine
nécessaire qui pourrait faire craindre
aux collectivités de s'engager dans des
investissements lourds avec des risques
importants il s'agit notamment de
l'activation et du maintien du réseau
cuivre sur lequel beaucoup
d'interrogations et des risques de
substitution ou de l'investissement de
fibres optiques dans l'usage pourrait
être évité par les opérateurs la
troisième garantie est d'ordre
réglementaire et concerne activation des
réseaux fibres optiques qui ne seraient
être laissés à la seule discrétion des
opérateurs parmi les priorités des
collectivités il y a bien évidemment les
espaces économiques dans les stations
touristiques sont une composante forte
pouvez-vous préciser les conditions dans
lesquelles l'opérateur d'un RIP peut
intervenir sur le segment entreprises
notamment sur les secteurs où il existe
déjà une offre de groupe y compris à
l'intérieur des périmètres des zones
interventions conventionnées amis et
préciser les modalités d'attribution des
aides de l'État sur les segments de
marché d'entreprise dans ces zones
géographiques enfin une bonne part des
zones prioritaires imposées aux
opérateurs pour le déploiement de la
couverture 4G est située en secteur de
montagne est-il possible d'imposer aux
opérateurs titulaires des licences 4G de
s'engager sur une départementalisation
de leur calendrier de couverture
notamment pour l'échéance intermédiaires
de 2017 ne faisant référence qu'à des
objectifs chiffrés au niveau national
sans carte graphique précise
merci madame la ministre
monsieur sénateur d'abord je voudrais
m'excuser je vous ai répondu en franc
monsieur Mirassou donc je sais pas si
une crise de jeunesse ou de faiblesse
mais c'est bien 12 millions et demi
d'euros donc je vais faire très
attention notamment sur les montants qui
sont
mobilisés par l'État qui sont très
importants en faveur du programme France
très haut débit qui introduit bien des
éléments prenant contre la spécificité
des territoires difficiles à équiper
comme les zones de montagne les taux
d'intervention en effet été majorées et
il est critères de calcul tiennent
compte de la dispersion de l'habitat
comme du taux de ruralité ce qui permet
de coller réellement la réalité des
coûts notamment dans les territoires de
montagne le périmètre des dépenses
éligibles étant d'autre assez large car
il comprend les réseaux de collecte et
les raccordements finaux ce programme
concernant priorité le déploiement de la
fibre au plus près de l'usager ce qui
constitue une première étape du
développement du réseau optique les
équipements d'activation du réseau cuves
ne sont pas financés par l'État et la
collectivité reste maîtresse du choix de
technologie quel emploi en ce qui
concerne précisément le basculement du
cuivre vers la fibre le gouvernement a
créé une mission scientifique dont la
conduite a été confiée à Monsieur Paul
chans ancien président de l'Autorité de
Régulation des Télécommunications sur le
cas particulier que vous citez du
segment marcher entreprise dans les
zones amies vous savez que conformément
la réglementation européenne les aides
de l'État ne soutiennent les rips que
sur les territoires des pourvus
d'initiatives privées il faut absolument
rentrer dans ce cadre quoi que nous en
pensions enfin sur la question de la 4G
les obligations des opérateurs sont bien
départementalisés puisque le taux de
couverture devra être devra être de
99,6% de la population nationale à 2027
et au moins de 90% de la population de
chaque département français à 2024 et
95% en 2027 il y a bien donc un objectif
départementalisé en outre l'accélération
de ce déploiement est envisageable sur
tel ou telle des territoires suivant des
modalités identifiés entre opérateurs et
collectivités je veillerai à ce que
cette mobilisation soit menée en
particulier dans les territoires ruraux
ou le déploiement de la 4G pour des
usages fixes ou mobiles est encore plus
important et urgent
merci Monsieur VIAL
oui madame le ministre merci pour vos
réponses extrêmement précises notamment
sur le premier point en ce qui concerne
l'aide de l'État avec un taux majoré que
j'ai bien noté sur la situation du
cuivre j'ai noté effectivement la
mission de nez à Monsieur champsa il
s'agit Madame le Ministre d'une question
tout à fait importante car bien
évidemment en fonction des décisions qui
seront prises et vous savez les
inquiétudes que les élus peuvent avoir
compte tenu de ce qui s'est dit à ce
sujet il s'agit d'un élément non
négligeable dans le choix de des schémas
mis en place par les collectivités en ce
qui concerne les zones à mis les zones
entreprises dans les dans les zones
couvertes notamment zone amie la
ministre j'insiste sur ce point il est
quand même pour le moins paradoxal que
les opérateurs puissent déclarer
préempter un territoire et que dans ce
territoire il y a les zones économiques
qui constituent quand même une priorité
et sur lesquels les collectivités ont
très peu de garantie pour ne pas dire
aucune merci beaucoup
merci Monsieur Pierre Bernard RA